smart looking tatum catches tatum shoots  tatum scores  tatum's got to put it up step back  three-pointer  jason tatum from downtown  smart inside the tatum spins falling  away off one but it's good again  wow 38 points for jason tatum fearless  in the big moments he's got 14 points  smart kicks it out in the corner tatum  three-pointer puts it in  jason tatum with his seventh  three-pointer  holiday playing physical with tatum  tatum on the drive  lays it in and the foul tatum tried to  slam it somebody got a piece of it  and jason tatum with a chance for a  three-point play  [Applause]  and there's the buzzer there'll be a  game seven between the bucks and the  celtics thanks to a career-defining  performance from jason tatum  here an elimination game on the road 46  points  and the celtics tie the series at three  games apiece